[Music]
these are the Inuits one of the few
tribes that despite having contact with
Western culture have managed to keep
their traditions alive the first thing
you need to know about them is that the
word Eskimo is extremely offensive this
is why we call them Inuits even though
greenland is part of denmark they have
their own laws their own language and
their own governments and in the past
few years lots of Chinese Australian and
American investors have flocked here why
well I guess you might be able to figure
that one out natural resources wise
Greenland is the new Africa there's oil
gas zinc gold there's plenty of it and
it's mainly unexploited this explains
why Donald Trump is suddenly so
interested in this territory at the end
of this video you'll understand why that
interest is not quite as crazy as it
might seem
[Applause]
[Music]
imagine a village with little more than
50,000 inhabitants that the oil reserves
of Russia
this is Greenland's current situation
and this is why news like this is to be
taken seriously
no jokes Trump really does want to buy
Greenland yes I know when it comes to
Donald Trump it's hard to tell whether
he's kidding on our sands of course
tweets like this don't make it any
easier I promise I will not do this to
green man but this time
it makes a lot of sense we all know that
Trump is trying hard to make history and
this is perhaps one of his less crazy
attempts to achieve that goal the one
it's not the first time that America has
tried to buy Greenland's back in the
1950s president harry s truman made a
solid purchasing offer to the Danish
crown and let's not forget that America
has already bought many other lands from
other countries Louisiana Florida and
Alaska were bought from France Spain and
Russia respectively and finally when it
comes to natural resources Greenland is
the promised land
Ireland is widely believed to host
several natural resources including lead
zinc iron or gold copper and last but
certainly not least dare old
and if all the studies are right
Greenland contains 15% of the world's
undiscovered oil beds but if you still
aren't fully convinced the Trump's not
crazy for trying to buy Greenland here's
the real deal
Greenland's political status is far from
clear yes right now it's not honest
region within the Kingdom of Denmark but
its political autonomy is growing and in
the future it might become an
independent country now the question
becomes well how do you even buy
countries or territories is Greenland's
are really that good of an investment
and would Greenlandic citizens have a
say in what happens well today we're
going to answer all of these questions
and more but before we do let's take a
look back at the history empires through
sale usually countries expand by violent
conquering or peaceful annexation but
these are the only formulas our story
begins in 1803 when Thomas Jefferson the
third President of the United States
purchased about eight hundred and twenty
eight thousand square miles of territory
from Napoleon's France this is what we
know of today as the states of Louisiana
Missouri Arkansas Iowa North Dakota
South Dakota Nebraska and Oklahoma for
fifteen million dollars the u.s. doubled
the size of its young Republic of course
it sparked a bit of controversy back
then but France badly needed the money
Napoleon he wanted to conquer Europe
which was far from cheap and America
wanted to become a grown-up country soak
the treaty was signed and immediately
after one of the signers founding father
robert Livingston made this famous
statement
[Music]
I've lived long but this is the noblest
work of our whole lives from this day
the United States takes their place
among the powers of the first rank but
this is not the end of the story you see
the 19th century offered lots of
opportunities for a young Republic to
expand the Spanish Empire was at the
brink of bankruptcy and it was trying to
keep its colonies in South America then
France was putting all of its conquering
energies into Africa so basically they
couldn't care less about North American
territories and again they needed money
and this is when America was more than
willing to do business America's second
big purchase was Florida
in 1819 even though Spain had long
rejected the u.s. as office to purchase
the territory the kingdom of Spain was
having some serious trouble in the
colonies several revolutions in Central
and South America demanded their
attention and the kingdom was worn out
by the war against Napoleon in Europe so
the king had to make a tough decision
and that's how Florida was ceded to the
US which is largely seen as a great
diplomatic victory from that moment on
the US was more than happy to acquire
new territories from Mexico Spain
Germany etc but the biggest purchase
came decades later and that of course
Alaska
[Music]
yes America's biggest state was bought
from Russia for 7.2 million in 1867 tsar
alexander ii decided to sell it because
the territory would be very difficult to
defend should any future conflict arise
the deal made some politicians frown but
it soon became clear that hadn't been a
great move between the purchase in 1867
in the final Alaskan gold rush in the
Klondike many people flocked the region
looking to fulfill their own American
dream
[Applause]
Alaska only managed to become a state in
1959 and according to reports extractive
industries accounted for 15 percent of
its GDP in 2016 and what do these
industries extract exactly well yes of
course that would be oil as of now asker
is one of the top five crude oil
producers in the nation and the state's
output in 2017 was the highest in three
years the state also ranks third in the
u.s. for natural gas production so again
weird as it might sound buying Alaska
from the Russians was actually a pretty
solid investment but ok I know what
you're thinking all that land was
purchased from absolute monarchies or
colonial powers the people living there
they didn't have much say about who they
wanted to be governed by but now things
have changed green lenders have rights
and they vote in elections and besides
is Greenland's really such a great
business opportunity well let's have a
look shall we
[Music]
the would-be richest country on earth
and despite the enormous wealth of
resources Greenlanders have under their
feet their most important industry at
the moment is fishing which contributes
90% of the islands total export value in
fact more than a third of these 56,000
people living in Greenland work one way
or another for the Danish government
some of them are civil servants and
others are employed at some subsidizing
company like a shopping mall yep you
heard that right Greenland's capital
nuke has little more than 16 thousand
inhabitants and they have a mall that is
paid for with Danish money every year
Denmark stands around 530 million u.s.
dollars in transfers to Greenland that's
more than nine thousand dollars per
inhabitant every year and Denmark
citizens they get little in return but
things are changing
[Music]
a few years ago a lot of Chinese and
Australian mining companies started
showing interest in Greenland's
potential and that's when Europe
realized they couldn't let the Chinese
be the only waters
we need innovative partnerships with
other countries over raw materials
companies are pushing the commission for
this they need this to survive Europe is
not so wealthy in raw materials and
needs to do better at forming
partnerships with other countries
antonio tejani european commissioner of
industry in 2012 and the question is why
I mean having so much oil and other
resources
why don't they exploit that wealth it's
because of environmental concerns please
the let's be serious here of course
everybody would love to exploit this
natural resources but good luck drilling
under a kilometer thick layer of ice yes
just a guess you didn't realize
Greenland has a ton of ice and in some
places we're talking about layers that
can surpass one kilometer in thickness
and even though climate change might
make things easier it also creates other
problems that oil we're talking about is
concentrated on the coast and if you
thought the Greenlandic coastline was
like the frozen version of Venice Beach
well you better think again
you know that iceberg that sunk the
Titanic well chances are that it came
from Greenland's most of the icebergs in
the Atlantic they come from there and
we're talking about an ice rock that is
as big as a residential building when it
breaks off from the mainland in just a
matter of minutes believe me you don't
want to have an oil platform right next
to a place where icebergs are forming
and guess what more the ice cap melts
the more icebergs there are but assuming
that you manage to find a way to extract
some oil from a safe spot or drill
through a 1 kilometer thick layer of ice
then you'll have the next problem and
that's infrastructure for example in the
northernmost part of the islands an
Australian company is preparing to
exploit zinc mine once they finish
building the project it might even
become the world's biggest zinc mine but
don't forget that the distance from that
line to the Greenland's at capital nuke
is as far as the distance from a central
Norway to Gibraltar which is near Spain
and there are no roads no railways to
connect those two points remember that
the central part of Greenland is
completely unfit for human habitation in
fact only 3 percent of the island's
entire surface is fit for living this
explains why there are over 56,000
Greenlanders who are concentrated in
just a few villages of course though
that can still be mines that are
profitable a good example is the zinc
mine that we're talking about but in
order to make it happen this Australian
company whose name is ironbark had to
invest more than 500 million dollars in
other words in order to extract wealth
in Greenland you have to make a big
investment but let's stop talking about
economics and let's dig deeper into
politics because even if Greenland could
build that infrastructure and technology
became cheaper America would still need
to convince the Danish and the
Greenlanders to sell out to them and
well what are the chances of that
happening well let's find out
a strange relationship greenland's has
been part of the Kingdom of Denmark
since 1840 still they have kept most of
their Inuit tradition and laws and you
might wonder how is this possible how
can Denmark one of the most modern
countries on earth except a region where
they don't even have laws to grant
private lands and that's not all we're
talking about the area of the planet
with the world's highest suicide rate
where gender violence and Alcoholism
they're still pretty common and crime
rates outnumber those of any European
country the truth is that despite being
owned by the Kingdom of Denmark since
1814 Greenland's became an autonomous
region in 1974 basically an autonomous
County it became even more independent
in 2009 when more than 70% of
Greenlanders voted in favor of the
self-government act now Danish isn't
even the official language of the island
the government is pushing hard to have
the color suit language taught in all
schools Greenland even has the local
Parliament's so most of their
relationship with Copenhagen can be
summarised by the two reserved seats
that they have in the Danish Parliament
[Laughter]
this and of course the money because for
200 years Denmark has been transferring
money to Greenland and getting little in
return and especially after the 1950s
Denmark sought to transform Greenland
and its economy into a completely
self-sufficient one for example in the
1950s and 1960s Danish funded and Danish
designed housing and other
infrastructure contributed to turning
nuke Greenland's capital into a city if
you go to nuke you can find lots of
European amenities and malls all paid
for by Denmark but still life expectancy
is 10 years shorter than Denmark's
unemployment is high and the region has
as we mentioned the world's highest
suicide rate and in the cultural clash
which we Inuit tribalism and Danish
influence you can understand why so many
green lenders want to become a sovereign
nation they're independent is party is a
powerful force in Parliament and more
than 67 percent of the adult population
is convinced that independence is the
way to go I still believe that Greenland
will achieve independence during the
time that I'm still active in politics
alayka Hammond former Greenlandic
premier but as you can imagine Denmark
wants to keep Greenland's because after
decades of paying so much without
getting anything in return things may
finally change
[Music]
the country's set to cash in on climate
change record temperatures threaten
traditional ways of life in Greenland
but as the sea ice retreats new mining
fishing and tourism opportunities are
helping communities to adapt as global
warming continues to melt the Arctic ice
Greenland's resources are becoming more
accessible the political establishment
in Greenland has made extracting those
resources their focal point in order to
achieve full independence from Denmark
and again if you thought that those
Greenlandic nationalist politicians so
proud of their Inuit traditions are
diehard ecologist cyou will never sell
out to the big oil companies well you'd
better think again
three handers are very good at seeing
new opportunities we've simply refused
to be victimized due to climate change
I'm very optimistic
I see more positive options for the
country than negatives I wish that it
weren't happening but it is and that's a
fact once it's there you have an
obligation to do the best of it alayka
Hammond country's former prime minister
in fact in 2013 Greenland's Parliament's
reversed a decades-old ban on uranium
mining so another Australian mining
company Greenland minerals already has
plans for a major uranium and rare earth
minerals mine at a mountain in the
southern coast but it's not just about
the reserves is also about the Arctic
routes that might develop in the future
the receding ice cap is opening up the
Northwest Passage a change that has the
potential to completely reshape global
shipping
if this comes to pass we would be
talking about routes that would be a
gift for nations like China the passage
became ice free in 2007 in countries
soon began talking about it as a
potential seasonal alternative to the
Suez and Panama canal's since it would
enable the shippers to save time and
avoid pirate-infested regions all of
this explains why Trump is so interested
in Greenland's but the Danish government
is absolutely not willing to make this
purchase happen and then is not for sale
Greenland is not Danish Greenland
belongs to Greenland I strongly hope
that this is not meant seriously Danish
Prime Minister met Fredrickson responded
and this is the question that we have
for you do you think Greenlanders would
be happy to be sold to America should
they keep trying for independence do you
think they can really reap the benefits
of the enormous wealth that they have
under their feet well please leave your
answer in the comment section below
and of course don't forget to visit our
friends from reconsider Mediacom the
podcast that provided the voices in this
video that were not mine also if you
like this video remember that we publish
brand-new ones every week so hit that
subscribe button to avoid missing any
posts and as always I'll see you next
time and if you want to learn more about
politics and here even more of my love
the voice you can join us at reconsider
media we have a podcast at reconsider
mediacom slash podcast see you there
[Music]